sechs jahre und einen tag nach dem
deutschen überfall auf polen
unterzeichnet japan am 2 september 1945
die kapitulationsurkunde
der zweite weltkrieg ist beendet
wie viele menschen in diesem krieg
gestorben sind wird niemand je genau
wissen ebenso wenig den namen des ersten
oder den des letzten opfers
[Musik]
doch es sind menschen die in diesem
krieg gelitten und gekämpft haben
ohne sie wären panzer nicht gerollt
flugzeuge nicht geflogen
und schiffe nicht gefahren
[Musik]
im krieg geht es um menschen
mit oder
ohne uniform
[Musik]
menschen in städten
dörfern
welt an
verbündete fremde
[Musik]
verfeindeten nachbarn
hunderte millionen menschen
die sechs jahre und einen tag lang
die hölle auf erde durchlebten
[Musik]
nach dem blutvergießen des ersten
weltkriegs herrscht 1918 kein frieden
auch als nach monatelangen verhandlungen
1919 invers sei ein friedensvertrag
unterzeichnet wird hören die kämpfe
nicht auf
bürgerkrieg in russland dann in china
dann in spanien
invasion in äthiopien einmarsch in
österreich und der tschechoslowakei
der chaco krieg in südamerika
gewalt in den straßen in deutschland und
den usa
die menschen leiden unter hunger und
arbeitslosigkeit ein
diktator nach dem anderen ergreift die
macht
dann kommt ein tag der alles verändern
wird
der erste september 1939
[Musik]
die erste streitfrage zu diesem krieg
der in unterschiedlichen ländern
unterschiedliche namen trägt ist die
wann fing er an
der zweite weltkrieg begann in asien an
der luga brücke im westen wird sie marco
polo brücke benannt
nach einem feuergefecht zwischen
japanischen und chinesischen soldaten
sagt chang kai shek der vorsitzende der
chinesischen nationalregierung er wolle
eine friedliche lösung er fügt
allerdings hinzu
vielleicht ist jetzt die zeit zu
verkünden dass wir bereit zum kampf sind
[Musik]
eher verhängt den allgemeinen
alarmzustand
die truppen sollen sich für den
verteidigungsfall bereithalten
[Musik]
er vertrat die nation wohl mehr als
jeder andere
vor allem seine ehefrau mailing stellte
ihn als beschützer chinas dar der sich
den japanischen unterdrückern
entgegenstellt
die japaner nutzen den zwischenfall an
der marco polo brücke 1937 als vorwand
für einen großangriff auf china dies ist
eher inoffizielle auftakt für den
zweiten weltkrieg in asien
ging fällt nach zwei tagen tianjin
weitere zwei tage später als die von ihm
erwartete unterstützung durch
großbritannien und amerika ausbleibt
verkündet oberbefehlshaber junkie scheck
da es keine hoffnung mehr auf frieden
gibt bleibt uns nur bis zum bitteren
ende widerstand zu leisten
ein chinesischer offizier notiert in
seinem tagebuch heftiger japanischer
artillerie beschuss als wollten sie die
berge zum einsturz bringen und das mehr
wegwischen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
am 13 dezember 1937 besetzen die japaner
nanjing
[Musik]
es ist ein beispiel der brutalen gewalt
gegen zivilisten die im zweiten
weltkrieg mehr opfer in der bevölkerung
als unter soldaten fordern wird
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
wie viele menschen beim massaker von
nanjing getötet wurden wird sich wohl
niemals exakt feststellen lassen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es waren mindestens 50.000
möglicherweise aber auch sechs mal so
viele
tote werden in gruben geworfen
überlebende lebendig begraben ge
folterte und ermordete in den fluss
geworfen
japans militär sicherheitschef in
shanghai drückt den rassismus aus der
diese gewalt erst möglich macht
[Musik]
solchen kreaturen können wir alles antun
ein japanischer soldat hält in seinem
tagebuch fest
ich trat achtlos auf die leichen
chinesischer soldaten denn mein herz war
verroht
verstümmelte leichen werden verbrannt
frauen vergewaltigt und entstellt
früher hat man ereignisse wie das
massaker von nanjing für das ergebnis
unkontrollierte raserei aber inzwischen
wird deutlich bei den meisten
kriegsverbrechen an zivilisten in diesem
ausmaß dass sie viel kontrollierter
abliefen als vermutet
[Musik]
ein japanischer offizier schreibt
in friedenszeiten wären diese taten
völlig undenkbar und unmenschlich aber
in der seltsamen umgebung des
schlachtfeld fallen sie leicht
das bestätigt sich auf jedem
schlachtfeld auf jedem kontinent
europa schenk china slide wenig
beachtung dort zieht der anschluss alle
aufmerksamkeit auf sich
[Musik]
adolf hitler 1933 zum reichskanzler
ernannt und 1934 zum führer erklärt
hatte 1936 das entmilitarisierte
rheinland besetzt ein klarer bruch des
versailler vertrags trotzdem fiel kein
einziger schuss
zum sogenannten anschluss schickt hitler
truppen nach österreich
anschließend fordert er von der
tschechoslowakei die abtretung des
sudetenlandes
hauptsächlich von deutschen besiedelt
ist
[Musik]
der britische premierminister neville
chamberlain setzt mit seiner apps man
politik auf beschwichtigung
wurde stark kritisiert und für das
scheiternde peaceman politik
verantwortlich gemacht ich hingegen
finde das eher ehrenhaft und
nachvollziehbar gehandelt hat
er hat sich in seinem denken stark von
briefen beeinflussen lassen die an ihn
gerichtet wurden er bekam säckeweise
post und zwar hauptsächlich von frauen
von müttern und ehefrau
[Applaus]
müssen er war nicht der gutgläubige
idiot als den ihn manche darstellen er
traut der hitler nicht er wollte das
beste raus schlagen
[Musik]
die apm und politik gipfelt im münchner
abkommen von 1938
[Musik]
in münchen ging es darum zeit zu
schenken weil man nicht kriegs bereit
war und es ging darum optionen
auszuloten von denen es immer weniger
gab
[Musik]
[Applaus]
deutschlands bekommt das sudetenland
zugesprochen unter der bedingung keine
weiteren territorialansprüche zu stellen
bei der es um wenige monate später
verstieß hinter dagegen
würde die zukunft zur bibel war adolf
hitler drohte park durch die luftwaffe
zu vernichten sollte sich das land nicht
bedingungslos den schutz des deutschen
reiches unter stimmen
hiess es anfang 1939 schickt er dann
panzer und übernimmt den rest der
tschechoslowakei
[Gelächter]
er wird den beteiligten klar dass dieser
mann vor nichts und niemandem halt macht
das auch von der tschechoslowakei bewies
dass heute anstelle des kleinen fingers
dann zur hand nehmen würde
[Musik]
als nächstes will hitler polen franz
halder chef des generalstabs des heeres
bringt die absicht des diktators auf den
punkt nämlich
das polnische volk zu vernichten und
auszurotten
in deutschland läuft derweil die
propagandamaschine auf hochtouren
es werden falsche berichte gestreut die
polnische armee hätte die territoriale
integrität des deutschen reiches
verletzt
deutschland sei von polen provoziert
worden holen würde aufrüsten das land
habe die beistandsgarantie der briten
und der franzosen und es unterdrücke die
deutsche minderheit im land
[Musik]
[Applaus]
am ersten september 1939 um 447 eröffnet
das deutsche kadetten schulschiff
schleswig holstein das feuer auf
polnische befestigungen auf der
halbinsel westerplatte
ohne vorwarnung oder kriegserklärung
überfallen deutsche truppen polen
mit wehrmacht luftwaffe und kriegsmarine
verteidiger versuchen die untersuchung
mit allen mitteln abzuwehren
der auschwitz überlebende masche
fischmann erinnert sich
plötzlich tauchten deutsche bombe auf
ohne kriegserklärung
[Musik]
es wurden freiwillige gesucht
wir sollten die feuer löschen
den brand bomben hatten wir nichts
entgegenzusetzen wir hatten nur einmal
mit wasser
nach dem anderen wird erobert und die
motorisierten kutsche fahren in richtung
warschau
die wehrmacht marschiert mit 1,5
millionen soldaten ein verteilt auf 61
divisionen
[Musik]
1929 modernen deutschen flugzeugen
stehen
842 meist ältere polnische maschinen
gegenüber
[Musik]
auf diesen tag hatte deutschland
gewartet und sich vorbereitet mit dem
herzen kosten sie die zerstörung aus die
sie über die welt brachten
hans lehmann ist einer der deutschen
soldaten
als wir in polen einmarschierten lagen
überall leichen
sie lagen einfach da und niemand scherte
sich darum
[Musik]
die unmittelbare reaktion der alliierten
auf den überfall auf polen war dass sie
deutschland den krieg erklären aber rein
praktisch standen sie vor einem problem
denn sie konnten nicht ohne weiteres
truppen oder kriegsgerät nach polen
bringen
hermann göring
oberbefehlshaber der luftwaffe es durch
die britische kriegserklärung beunruhigt
wenn wir diesen krieg verlieren dann
gnade uns gott
am 6 september ist die warschauer
luftabwehr schon stark dezimiert
die voest warschau war die erste
großstadt die aus der luft bombardiert
wurde das leid war groß die stadt wurde
zu etwa 20 prozent zerstört es lagen
leichen auf den straßen
stephans kaczynski der warschauer
bürgermeister berichtet in den frühen
morgenstunden wurden sieben unserer
krankenhäuser bombardiert
wie bei früheren luftangriffen verletzt
worden waren lagen in diesem betten als
dieser angriff kam wie ein
unerbittlicher rächer der niemand kommen
lassen heute sie sollten keinen frieden
finden
jadwiga sonst of ska ist damals
krankenschwester ein 16-jähriges mädchen
die beine nur noch eine blutige masse
ich beugte mich zu jung küste ihre
brauen sie starb ganz still
[Musik]
am 13 september verursachen sturz
kampfbomber großflächige brände
am 25 schließlich geht auf warschau der
umfangreichste luftangriff nieder die
welt bisher erlebt hat
es herrschte die überzeugung große
städtische gebiete ins visier zu nehmen
würde zum sieg führen zu einem gewissen
grad ging es im weiteren verlauf auch
darum diese strategie nach und nach
umzusetzen
der augenzeuge abraham goldberg
berichtet die deutschen stars flogen
über uns hinweg und schossen mit
maschinengewehren auch auf soldaten auf
dem rückzug es gab viele tote
[Musik]
schiebe im mittleren alter waren zornig
und wütend die jungen waren halb
verbittert weil prosiegel mit begleitung
trost im gebiet suchten das sind die
gesichter einer nation im
belagerungszustand
[Musik]
mit dem krieg beginnt auch der gezielte
terror gegen die zivilbevölkerung
die deutschen truppen sollen angst und
schrecken verbreiten
in hitlers worten ich schicke meine
totenkopf verbände nach osten mit dem
befehl ohne gnade und erbarmen alle
männer frauen und kinder polnische rasse
und sprache zu töten
[Musik]
am tag der britischen und französischen
kriegserklärung treiben die deutschen im
dorf tross collage 55 bauern zusammen
und erschießen sie
[Musik]
es wurden schon vorher menschen ermordet
getötet und vertrieben aber nie in den
dimensionen wie im dritten reich wär
hätte damit rechnen können dass so etwas
geschieht
[Musik]
während die wehrmacht in polen vorrückt
bewegen sich rund 100.000 japanische
soldaten in sechs divisionen auf die
chinesische stadt changsha zu
einige meinen japan ging es um expansion
in asien
nicht zuletzt weil ein schwaches china
und ein schwaches korea japan selbst
angreifbar machen würden angesichts des
aggressiven westlichen imperialismus
der japanische soldat chor isaias meldet
sich als jugendlicher freiwillig zum
dienst an der waffe
behörden geschichten über andere die für
unser land gestorben waren die schule
bestand im grunde daraus dass auch wir
lernten für unser land zu sterben die
chinesischen truppen die changsha
verteidigen sind in japanern waffen
technisch unterlegen doch sie können den
angriff abwehren unter dem kommando von
general schuljahr er schreibt wir haben
china zerstört keinen stein auf dem
anderen gelassen jeden hof
niedergebrannt jedes gleis zerlegt und
wir waren dabei so erfolgreich dass die
japaner ihren einmarsch bereut haben
und because of tea in die bedrohung
durch die imperialisten und durch die
invasion der japaner ebenfalls in
realisten führte den chinesen vor augen
dass sie gegen diese äußeren feinde
zusammenhalten mussten
standen starker
widerstand
[Musik]
die japanische politik zielt auf
expansion auf den gewinn von land und
rohstoffen ein lager will nach norden
vorrücken ein anderes im süden zu
schlagen die entscheidung bringt eine
schlacht zwischen japanischen und
sowjetischen truppen an der mongolischen
grenze
bei kämpfen der fahrer und jetzt
gegeneinander
flugzeuge werden abgeschossen diese
kampfflieger 38 ihren zu stützen zurück
[Musik]
die niederlage der japaner in der
mongolei stärkte ihre überzeugung dass
sie nach süden ziehen mussten um sich zu
retten statt nach norden
das sowjetische japanische
waffenstillstandsabkommen nach der
schlacht am kalki ingolstadt ins grenzen
in asien vor japanischen angriffen
so kann die rote armee ganz beruhigt in
ostpolen einmarschieren wie es im august
1939 im deutsch sowjetischen
nichtangriffspakt
heimlich mit hitler vereinbart wurde die
vernichtung polens würde einen
bourgeoisen faschisten staat weniger
bedeuten mit dem man sich herumschlagen
muss
die polnische armee war völlig
überrumpelt denn es war nicht klar
welche absicht die rote armee verfolgte
die polnische armee im kampf gegen die
nazis unterstützen oder einen teil des
landes für weißrussland einnehmen
was hunderte wochen wurden angriffen
durch die luftwaffe widersetzte sich die
hauptstadt polens mit ihren 1 millionen
einwohnern drei wochen lang den
übermächtigen gegner abgeschnitten mit
schwindenden nahrungs und wasservorräte
und völlig unzureichenden
verteidigungsanlagen war warschau ein
großes ziel für das bomben und
geschossen trotzdem kämpfte war schon
weiter bis zum 27 september
schließlich kapituliert warschau
ein deutscher soldat hält fest
schwere polnische geschützter werden von
unseren soldaten abtransportiert laster
sind auf dem weg in die wälder um die
gefangenen wegzubringen
am 28 september spielt radio warschau
chopins trauermarsch am 29 teil nazis
und sowjets das land zwischen sich auf
bis zu 100.000 polnische soldaten sind
bei den kämpfen ums leben gekommen über
400.000 weitere geraten in deutsche
kriegsgefangenschaft
250.000 in sowjetische
[Musik]
siegmund glukhovsky lebt damals in
warschau
die deutschen erließen neue vorschriften
alle jüdischen männer zwischen 15 und 60
mussten mit besen schaufeln und eimern
am rathaus antreten um die straßen zu
reinigen
[Musik]
wegen der besatzung steigt die anzahl
jüdischer menschen unter ns herrschaft
von 300.000 auf drei millionen
heinrich himmler reichsführer ss und
einer der mächtigsten männer des
ns-regimes macht keinen hehl aus dessen
plänen es wird höchste zeit dass dieses
gesindel zusammengetrieben wird in
ghettos und dann schleppt solchen hinein
und lasst sie krepieren
an den schulen wurde jetzt die
sogenannte rassenlehre unterrichtet
entsprechend der ns ideologie
unter diesem aspekt wurde von nun an
geschichte betrachtet
wenige wochen nach dem überfall beginnen
die nazis den völkermord in polen im
herbst 1939 ermorden angehörige der ss
und des volksdeutschen selbst schutzes
in den wäldern um das dorf pia schnitzer
zwischen 10 und 13 tausend menschen
alles was folgte kann man nur verstehen
wenn man sich ansieht was da für eine
identität geschaffen wurde und was für
eine vorstellung vom deutsch seien die
menschen annahmen und verinnerlichten
der schriftsteller george orwell spricht
vielen aus der seele
wie millionen anderen scheint mir die
welt aus den fugen geraten
[Musik]
als reaktion auf den überfall auf polen
wirft großbritannien 12 millionen
flugblätter über deutschland ab ein
britischer abgeordneter spricht ironisch
vom konfetti krieg
hitlers propagandaminister joseph
goebbels hält in seinem tagebuch fest
beim führer er ist der meinung dass
england einen ko hieb bekommen muss das
stimmt auch
am 9 oktober ergeht hitlers weisung
nummer sechs für die kriegsführung
hitler befiehlt eine offensive im westen
in den niederlanden belgien und
nordfrankreich
doch die generelle überzeugen ihn bis
zum frühjahr zu warten frankreich und
england bleiben ebenfalls zunächst
passiv diese phase wird später als
sogenannter sitz krieg in die
geschichtsbücher eingehen
währenddessen wollten die nazis in polen
weiter
[Musik]
der kapitulation natürlich die
stadt gelegt durchströmen von berichten
über widerwärtige grünen taten die die
bedeutung so genannte einsatzgruppen
sondereinheiten der ss ermordet
mindestens 60.000 angehörige staatlicher
eliten darunter ärzte rechtsanwälte
professoren lehrer journalisten und
priester außerdem tausende juden und
psychisch kranke menschen die
rassentheorie der nazis war ein
pseudowissenschaftlich sie hatte keine
biologische grundlage
joseph goebbels schreibt in seinem
tagebuch
für das urteil über die polin ist
vernichtend mehr tiere als menschen
gänzlich stumpf und am auf hitler sagt
es muss verhindert werden dass eine
polnische intelligenz sich als führer
schicht auf macht in dem lande soll ein
niederer lebensstandard bleiben wir
wollen dort nur arbeitskräfte schöpfen
auch die sowjetische besatzung ist sogar
noch brutaler als die deutsche in diesen
ersten anderthalb jahren sterben mehr
polen durch die hand der sowjets als der
deutschen
[Musik]
die sowjetunion nimmt rund
250.000 polnische soldaten gefangen
zwischen 22.000 und 25.000 berufs oder
reserve offiziere polizisten und
intellektuelle werden später in den wald
von katyn und an andere orte verschleppt
und von sowjetischen truppen erschossen
am 15 oktober nimmt hitler die sieges
parade der wehrmacht in der polnischen
hauptstadt ab
großbritannien verhält sich weiter
passiv und frankreich verlässt sich ganz
auf die maginot linie ein komplexes gut
ausgebautes verteidigungssystem entlang
der französisch deutschen grenze ein
ja und die französische armee marschiert
am rhein einige kilometer auf deutsches
gebiet und zog sich dann wieder zurück
bestärkt durch den erfolg in polen
schickt josef stalin die rote armee im
november nach finnland er will die
einstigen grenzen wie zu alten zeiten
der zaren herrschaft wieder herstellen
über das wetter war aktiv der schnee lag
ein meter hoch man sollte meinen die
russen kämen damit zurecht aber sie
waren unglaublich schlecht vorbereitet
und das machten sich die finden zunutze
der winter krieg wird zur blamage für
die sowjets
verteidigungsminister wo rohstoffmacht
stalin und dessen säuberungsaktionen
dafür verantwortlich das haben sie
allein sich selbst zuzuschreiben sie
haben die alte garde in der armee
vernichtet sie haben unsere besten
generäle umbringen lassen
das straucheln der roten armee bringt
die nazis zu einer fatalen
fehleinschätzung
goebbels bekundet in finnland kommen die
russen gar nicht vorwärts die rote armee
scheint ja in der tat nur sehr wenig
wert zu sein
finnland war ja viel kleiner als das
deutsche reich daraus schloss hitler
dass er in der lage sei gegen die
sowjets in den krieg zu ziehen und sie
vernichtend zu schlagen
um sogenannten lebensraum zu gewinnen
will hitler noch mehr gebiete im osten
erobern ohne dabei einen
zweifrontenkrieg zu riskieren
über seine pläne für 1940 sagt er
goebbels
ich will england schlagen koste es was
es wolle
für die nazis hatten mehrere ziele sie
wollten auch frankreich besiegen aber
aus sicht hitlers und der deutschen
würde sich der eigentliche krieg immer
im osten abspielen
[Musik]
in japan und deutschland hat die
rationierung bereits vor dem krieg
begonnen anfang 1940 wird sie auch in
großbritannien eingeführt sie ist nicht
besonders durchdacht oder genau
ausgearbeitet die rationen richten sich
danach was die menschen unbedingt
brauchen
augenzeugen die damals noch kinder waren
erinnern sich
wir hatten ration hefte in drei farben
braun für erwachsene blau für
jugendliche und grün für kinder
auf jeder seite waren kleine kästchen
mit buchstaben darin
mein gegen meter ration skate in den
laden und dort wurde das kästchen
durchgestrichen das hieß dass man seine
wochenration erhalten hatte
dieses große krieg sanierung für
experimente nicht an weißen mäusen oder
versuchskaninchen durchgeführt sondern
an menschen die unter guten kämpfen
[Musik]
menschen die im fadenkreuz der deutschen
rassenpolitik stehen sehen sich
schwierigkeiten ganz andere dimensionen
ausgesetzt
[Musik]
joseph goebbels vermerk in seinem
tagebuch
himmler verschiebt augenblicklich die
völker nicht immer mit erfolg
heinrich himmler reichsführer ss lässt
die menschen in lager und ghettos
verschleppen seit anfang 1940 kommt in
polen auch eine mobile gaskammer zum
einsatz
doch das kriegsgeschehen scheint zum
stillstand gekommen zu sein
großbritanniens premierminister neville
chamberlain hält fest
aus welchem grund auch immer hitler
keine anstalten gemacht hat uns zu
überrumpeln eines ist sicher der zug ist
abgefahren
diese aussage stammt vom vierten april
in den morgenstunden des 9 april beginnt
operationen weser übung der überfall auf
dänemark und norwegen
schon am abend des ersten tages haben
die deutschen truppen ihre zielvorgaben
erreicht am nachmittag
konnten die deutschen an sie berufen an
denen sie am morgen gelandet waren
die versuche der alliierten den
deutschen in norwegen entgegenzutreten
bänden desaströs in trondheim sind ihre
streitkräfte den deutschen sechs zu eins
überlegen oder leiden trotzdem eine
niederlage
die royal navy muss
11.300 soldaten evakuieren und hat über
4000 opfer zu beklagen
[Musik]
der überfall auf norwegen hat die
deutschen fast die hälfte ihrer
überwasser streitkräfte gekostet eine
invasion englands über den ärmelkanal
ohne luftüberlegenheit wird so unmöglich
die briten profitieren indem sie die
norwegische handelsmarine übernehmen
[Musik]
die dusche benito mussolini der erste
faschistische diktator in europa ist in
italien seit 1922 an der macht er fühlt
sich angesichts der erfolge deutschlands
zurückgesetzt mit tragischen folgen für
sein gesamtes volk
in seiner entscheidung in den zweiten
weltkrieg einzutreten war eine
katastrophe für italien
[Musik]
auch im britischen unterhaus hat die
niederlage von norwegen folgen
neville chamberlain hat die
unterstützung seiner partei verloren und
tritt zurück
seine potenziellen nachfolger finden
keine mehrheit bei der opposition
also wird ein kompromisskandidat zum
regierungschef ernannt
winston churchill
[Musik]
churchill wurde als eine art
feingeistige liberaler demokrat
dargestellt tatsächlich war er einen
whisky surfen der konservative genau das
brauchen wir um hitler etwas
entgegenzusetzen
[Musik]
winston churchill ist 65 jahre alt
jetzt ist seine zeit gekommen
[Applaus]
das land 150 der deutsche soldat stellt
sich die gesamte menschheit überzeugt
von seiner macht zu zerstören und zu
erobern wo werden mit luftdruck was
richtig zuschlagen die antwort lässt
bislang auf sich warten 150 deutsche
divisionen erhalten befehl über
westeuropa erreichen
am 10 mai dem tag von churchills
amtsantritt beginnt hitlers überfall auf
belgien die niederlande frankreich und
luxemburg
der sogenannte blitzkrieg
die deutsche luftwaffe bereitet den
boden für die offensive gegen die
niederlande belgien das keine schutzlose
luxemburg vorbereiten endlichen
schrecken über diese länder zu bringen
die bezeichnung blitzkrieg beschrieb
natürlich in gewissem maße eine fiktion
selbst hitler hast du das wort
der blitzkrieg ist eine interessante
taktik sie funktioniert nicht nur für
die truppen am boden sondern auch
psychologisch
innerhalb von vier tagen hat die
maschine wieder früh kroatischen
unterirdischen widerstand gebrochen
[Musik]
städte und dörfer brannten nieder
während ihm versuchen in atemberaubender
geschwindigkeit voran rollten die
verteidiger um zu helfen und sie von den
städten im namen der wollen auch ute
stöttner häuser und geschäfte derer die
sich zu widersetzen bewahrt hatten
joseph goebbels formuliert das ziel des
feldzugs
der führer ist entschlossen zum großen
krieg gegen england sobald das wetter
gut ist
england muss aus europa heraus gefegt
und frankreich als großmacht abgesetzt
werden dann hat deutschland die
hegemonie und europa den frieden das ist
auch unser großes ewiges ziel
während der deutsche west feldzug in
vollem gange ist erklärt mussolini
frankreich und großbritannien den krieg
seine armee ist kleiner und schlechter
ausgestattet als im ersten weltkrieg
graf ciano mussolinis außenminister und
schwiegersohn hält in seinem tagebuch
fest ich bin sehr sehr traurig möge gott
italien beistehen
zwei tage nach churchill amtsantritt am
12 bei betreten die ersten deutschen
einheiten französischen boden und
sichern das nordufer der mars
feldwebel weiter robert ist teil des
vordersten stoßtrupps mit meinem club
stieß sich schnell bis ans ufer der maas
vor feindlicher maschinengewehr beschuss
von der rechten flanke während der
überquerung nahmen unsere
maschinengewehre den feind unter
sperrfeuer so dass wir keine verluste zu
beklagen hatten
[Musik]
die maginot-linie war praktisch nutzlos
denn die deutschen griffen über die
niederlande und die ardennen an soweit
erstreckte sich die maginot-linie gar
nicht
am selben tag erhält die niederländische
armee oder sich für eine letzte schlacht
auf die verteidigungslinie amsterdam
rotterdam utrecht zurückzuziehen der
junge niederländische jude jude hahn
verbringt die gesamte kriegszeit in
einem versteck
in den niederlanden benahmen sich die
besatzer zunächst tadellos aber
die ruhe währte natürlich nicht lang
am tag der niederländischen kapitulation
bemerkt frankreichs regierungschef pol
renault wir sind geschlagen wir sind
besiegt wir haben die schlacht verloren
die front ist durchbrochen
der feind stößt massenhaft durch
[Musik]
schon am 15 mai enden die kämpfe bei
sedan
einer der orte an denen sie durchbrachen
da sie dann das hätte den franzosen klar
sein müssen denn dort waren sie schon
1870 geschlagen wurden trotzdem konnte
die wehrmacht einfach durch gärten
rauschen die deutschen überquerten die
markierten um sie dann und durch die
wälder der ardennen aber der brückenkopf
den sie errichteten relativ klein und
schwach verteidigt
die franzosen eine entschlossene
gegenoffensive gestartet hätten hätten
sie die deutschen wohl zurückschlagen
können haben sie aber nicht
ein britischer offizier schreibt in
seinem tagebuch man hielt den bereich um
sie dann offenbar für so gut gesichert
dass die franzosen dort nur die
schwächsten divisionen stationierten als
die sturz kampfbomber kamen hielten sie
dem angriff zwei stunden lang stand und
nahmen dann reis aus wie verängstigte
alte damen
ein französischer stabsoffizier hält
fest den fanta regte sich in die gräben
wurde roche bedacht die köpfe schon
unten zu halten
innerhalb von sieben tagen rücken die
deutschen truppen 320 kilometer weit vor
bis tief ins französische hinterland das
kaum noch verteidigt wird
[Musik]
es gab keinen wirklichen plan wie mit
dem panzer durchbruch in den ardennen
umzugehen war
jj ist teil des panzer regiments der
britischen armee
die straße aus polen mir war voller
leben der leichen die sich bewegten
anders kann ich sie nicht beschreiben
denn sie sahen nicht mehr aus wie
menschen es waren männer frauen und
kinder mit taschen kleine handwagen im
schlepptau die kinder sprachen und
spielten nicht ihr blick war leer nur
geradeaus gerichtet ins nichts
innerhalb eines monats begeben sich acht
millionen franzosen auf die flucht
augenzeugen berichten von szenen voller
schrecken und verzweiflung das ganze
land scheint sich plötzlich ausgegeben
zu haben
alles ist zusammengebrochen implodiert
am 21 mai trifft die siebte
panzerdivision unter generalmajor erwin
rommel in cambrai
am 24 mai kommt die deutsche panzer
gruppe kleist bestehend aus drei
panzerdivisionen keine 25 kilometer vor
den kirchen zum stehen
es folgt einer der häufig und heftig
diskutierten wendepunkte des krieges
[Musik]
eine der größten fehlentscheidungen
hitlers und seiner kommandeure während
des zweiten weltkriegs war der halter
befehl beim panzer vorstoß auf den
kirchen mit türmen zu münchen die
deutschen hatten drei wochen lang
gekämpft und waren erschöpft darum
ordneten die generelle an und nicht
hitler die viele denken kurz vor den
kirchen zu stoppen
vor allem die panzertruppen waren völlig
erschöpft von diesem unglaublich
schnellen vorstoß durch frankreich sie
konnten einfach nicht mehr
die order kommt von gerd von rund steht
oberbefehlshaber der heeresgruppe a
hitler unterstützt den befehl und
hermann göring jubelt so könne seine
luftwaffe den todesstoß gegen die in den
kirchen eingeschlossenen feindlichen
truppen vollführen wie er selbstbewusst
ankündigt
doch er irrt sich
der auch der feuerwehr verdunkelte fasst
die sonne mitten in diesem entfernung
konnte der britische expedition scrollen
seine französischen verboten die nazis
ihn aber gewaltige kraftanstrengung
abwehren er wolle nie wieder eine
sagenhafte rettungsaktion
[Musik]
am 26 mai beginnt die evakuierung
alliierter truppen aus den kirchen
die werke die evakuierung aus den
kirchen hatte viele folgen rein
praktisch betrachtet hatten die briten
damit hunderttausende männer gerettet
die weiterkämpfen konnten
bei der operation mit dem code namen
deiner mo kommen insgesamt rund 900
schiffe und boote zum einsatz vom
riesigen kriegsschiff bis zum kleinen
fischkutter und rettungsboot
die soldaten kamen an holzplanken und
wrackteil geklammert von den stränden
angeschwommen
die royal navy verlor dabei einige
schiffe sechs zerstöre wurden versenkt
aber das war es den briten wert statt
der erhofften
45.000 kann die flotte
338.000 alliierte soldaten evakuieren
[Musik]
doch die armee ist praktisch entwaffnet
die alliierten truppen haben 64.000
fahrzeuge
76.000 tonnen munition
und 2500 geschütze zurücklassen müssen
am 13 juni wird paris zur offenen stadt
erklärt um unnötige kämpfe abzuwenden am
14 führt generalleutnant von studnitz
die 87 infanterie division mitten durchs
zentrum
[Musik]
am 15 ergeben sich rund 400.000 soldaten
der eingekesselten dritten fünften und
achten französischen armee
am 22 juni folgt der waffenstillstand
von companion deutschland besetzt 60
prozent des landes der rest untersteht
einer französischen regierung mit sitz
in vichy am 24 juni besucht hitler paris
auf die frage nach einer sieges parade
sagt er
ich habe keine lust auf eine sieges
parade wir sind noch nicht am ende
[Musik]
der fall frankreichs beraubt die
alliierten kräfte der ressourcen einer
der wichtigsten industrienationen und
ergibt den nazis zugang zu frankreichs
helfen damit müssen die deutschen
u-boote nur noch halb so weit fahren um
die schifffahrtswege im atlantik zu
erreichen
frankreich ist gefallen
großbritannien ist aussicht gestellt
ohne verbündete
die stimmung in england ist düster
afa crutchlow und peter matthews wollen
als junger briten beim militär dienen
nach den kirchen wurden freiwillige
gesucht denn man ging natürlich von
einer invasion aus
zuerst bekam man eine armbinde und als
es dann wieder waffen gab endlich auch
ein gewehr
die angst vor einem deutschen überfall
geht um
general 1 seit
oberbefehlshaber der britischen heimat
verteidigung berichtet erzürnt
die ganze nacht schleichende
argwöhnische männer durchs land ständig
wird allerorts meldung gemacht der
französische general charles de gaulle
wendet sich über die bibi sie mit einem
appell aus london an seine landsleute
dieser krieg ist mit der schlacht um
frankreich nicht beendet dies ist ein
weltkrieg
am tag der übertragung von der goltz
rede sagt churchill im britischen
unterhaus die schlacht um frankreich ist
vorüber
[Musik]
nun steht uns die schlacht um
großbritannien bevor
[Musik]